- Evolve.
- Hello Believe Nation, today
we're going to talk about
how you need to evolve.
And as always guys, if you hear something
that really resonates with you,
please leave it down
in the comments below,
put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired.
And when you write it down yourself,
it's much more likely to
stick with you as well, enjoy!
(energizing music)
- You can only hope that
as a writer you start
trying different things and,
you try different chords or
different structures of songs.
Different beats that you've
never really explored
that path before.
You know,
I think,
having always been a writer first,
I'm obsessed with the syncopation of
the way that words sound when
they're said a certain way.
And, once I've done something
once, I always want to go
to a different direction and
never repeat myself so...
As a writer I think that I've always hoped
that my music would
constantly be changing because
you never want to make
the same album twice,
the same song twice and,
my greatest hope has been that as I grow,
my fans will grow up
with me, and as I change
and my life changes, my
music will change as well.
So wish me luck there.
- When I was younger I didn't
really know that you could
just get better at things.
'Cause I think we're so
used to the idea that
you're talented at something and,
it's sort of fixed.
The idea that, oh, he's just
a good singer, you know.
And, even with singing, I've
gotten better at singing
as I've gotten older.
I wasn't singing in a way
that was sustainable and
I wasn't breathing right, I wasn't doing
a bunch of things correctly.
I realized that there was a ceiling
that I couldn't crack
through unless I actually
studied and worked under
a coach to get better.
And,
this idea that things are just fixed
is proven not to be the case.
You can get better at
things, you can grow.
And even people that are innately talented
still need to go beyond
that basic talent that
they have and cultivate it.
- I've had to evolve so many times.
I've had to change and grow so many times!
There's been times where
I've made such huge mistakes
in my network marketing career.
Damaged relationships, done things that
I wish I could go back and
change, but I couldn't.
So I could either live there,
or I could use that information
to grow and become better.
See I've been involved for
25 years and I promise you,
every year that we're engaged,
we're working together,
every year you're going to see
me get a little bit better,
and a little bit better.
And most of the time I'm
not going to hit my goals,
but then I'm going to
get a little bit better,
and a little bit better
and compounded over time,
you'll see noticeable results.
Anybody that knows me knows
that I'm a different person
than I was five years ago,
10 years ago, 15 years ago.
Certainly 25 years ago.
18 jobs, you know, barely surviving.
So give yourself some grace.
Understand that nothing is ever finished
while you're still alive.
- So after you've been through the good,
the bad, the ugly, what do
you know for sure about life?
- That it moves on.
- Everybody says that.
- The truth.
- Just everybody's answer.
- It's the truth.
That it moves on and it
keeps going, and guess what,
it's going to move on and keep
going with or without you.
So you know you better
adjust to the changes
'cause if you don't adjust to
the changes, you stay stuck
in the way that you've been moving,
you're going to keep
getting what you've been
getting out of life,
and that's not the way
life is meant to be lived.
Life is meant to be lived...
You got to constantly evolve.
You know change is the basis of growth.
And growth is the basis of life.
If you're not constantly
changing, you're not growing.
If you're not growing
then what are you doing?
You're dying, you're not doing nothing.
So that's why when you
look at certain people man,
and you see them, and they're
40-something years old,
they washed up, 'cause
they still trying to live
the way they were when
they were in their 20s
and their 30s, nothing
about them has grown.
Nothing about them has evolved.
Their mindset hasn't grown,
their mindset hasn't evolved.
It's still hanging around the same people
they was hanging around when they were
in their 20s doing nothing.
So guess what, if you're
hanging around the same people
that you were hanging around
in your 20s doing nothing,
guess what you going to
be doing in your 30s?
Nothing, so guess what you
going to be doing in your 40s?
Nothing.
So you got to understand, life moves on.
Father time don't wait for nobody man,
and when it's over, it's over.
When you're 40-something
years old and you look back
and you're like damn, I wasted
all that time doing nothing.
You know?
Life moved on and I didn't move with it.
Now you just a washed individual.
You don't got nobody to
blame for that but yourself.
- But you came up with the
Waka Flocka record to this,
there's like a big
difference in your style,
in your approach, what's
the reason for that?
- Probably because we grow
and evolution is beautiful
and like, I want to be iconic
and great and I borderline
am iconic, and I am great so it's like,
the only thing left to do
- Tell me how you really feel.
- Is to just evolve and continue to do so,
and I'm responsible for
possibly bringing rock and
roll in general into hip hop
within our generation and
making that whole wave
a cool thing, and
influencing all those artists
when we were doing those
festivals back together
in the 2012, and 2011, 2010
years when Wild Boy was
a thing and when so
many other mixtape songs
that I was doing were a thing so like yes,
when I brought what I brought
in and everyone else took it,
I do what all trendsetters
do and I just set a new trend
and do on to the next thing
and let them keep doing that.
- Dream Team Minaj says, "I
love you, but I'm curious
"why did you change your rapping
style from the comeup days
"to today, I love both."
- I don't think I changed my rap style.
I think you guys were
just starting to hear me,
and you didn't hear all
of me yet, that's it.
I've always been into
being weird a little bit.
But,
I think what people really
mean is that they think
that I've changed my persona.
And,
life is about growth and change, and,
I don't want to remain the
same for my whole life.
I want to be able to change and
you know I respect the people who
loved
'07 Nicki, and I'm definitely going to
give you some stuff on Pink Friday.
I'm not forgetting anybody.
But I just also have to be true to me.
And the truth is, I started
seeing different things,
I started going different
places, I started
eating different things, I can't...
It would be fraudulent to rap the same way
and look the same way,
act the same way because
I am not the same, period.
I don't know to...
- Well everyone has their
different belief systems.
I think everyone has their
different opinions of
those types of things
that you talked about.
Certainly as an athlete, I care very much
what I put into my body, I
think that, I'm 38 years old.
I'm not 22 anymore.
- You look good.
(chuckling)
- You're very sweet, thank you.
You know, all those things are important.
And all the little things
add up to be big things so
when I'm trying to accomplish
things professionally that,
you know, in a lot of ways, I'm
in unchartered territory so,
I've got to do things
differently, and I got to evolve
over time, I've got to,
things that may have worked
in the past maybe don't
work as you move forward.
So the lessons that I've
learned through my own
trial and error, I think I'm at that point
in my career where I'm very efficient
with what I'm doing so,
I try to eat healthy,
I try to get the right amount of rest.
I try to do the right types of exercise
so I can be on the field
and be available to my team.
I try to be as productive
this time in my career
as I was earlier.
- Sure as we all have to
set goals for ourselves,
I mean, our planned destination is to be
busy.
And,
to,
adjust to whatever you,
whatever you're introduced to.
And what I mean by that
is OK, as an entertainer,
I started off as a singer.
You know I grew to become
a dancer and a performer.
After becoming a performer
then I became an actor.
After becoming an actor
I became an entrepreneur.
After becoming an entrepreneur
I became an entertainer
on a different level of
introducing other artists, then,
after that I became a mentor.
- Right.
- So I think just to
continue to evolve in a
way that is beneficial for
growth of myself and others, my likeness
to continue to be remembered
throughout history,
and associated with something great.
For me,
there's a mantra
that I've,
I've lived by.
And it is that,
the journey
of the destination is
really what it's all about.
The
pursuit
is more important than
the actual destination.
So as long as you are moving,
as long as you are working,
that is the destination.
- Wow.
- Yeah, the journey.
Or really it is simply that,
the journey is the destination.
- I agree.
- As long as you're working,
you're good.
- Fortunate enough to be honored at the
Essence Awards Luncheon for
the Fierce and Fearless Award,
and I was talking to my
girlfriend AJ Johnson
who was my trainer, but
she's also a life coach,
and I was like, do I tell it?
If I'm getting an award for
being fierce and fearless,
how 'about I really be fierce and fearless
and explain to people my evolution?
I love who I am today but
that wasn't always the case.
I didn't love my features,
I didn't love my weight,
I didn't love my hair,
I didn't love my lips.
And it's been an evolution,
and I wasn't always nice,
or as gracious as I could've been,
or happy for other people.
And just sort of explain that
journey through my speech.
- When you build up for Formula One,
you're obviously preparing to
race, but you're not prepared
for what comes along with
being a Formula One driver.
The pressure of such a big team, sponsors,
media, sitting onstage talking.
You're not prepared for that.
You're not put through a school
or through other interviews for it.
So you arrive in the deep end
without being able to swim
and I mean I made a lot of mistakes.
I got into, obviously
I was quick on track.
That was the easy part,
it was everything outside.
But,
lost the first year, in
2007 by one point which was,
depending on how seriously
you take your job,
it was emotionally
traumatizing the first year.
Came back the next year,
somehow came through that,
that experience, and
then in that last race,
I had to finish fifth.
I started third, I think
it was, and I was fourth,
fifth, and then with
probably like six laps,
seven laps to go or something,
I was down in sixth.
And the guy that was ahead
of me was Sebastian Vettel.
And,
there was,
I couldn't do anything even
to save my mother's life.
If my mom was over there
on the edge of a cliff,
I had to pass him in order to do it,
I couldn't get past him. (laughing)
You know, I couldn't
get past this guy and,
for those laps I just wasn't giving up.
But I could see that dream fading away.
And then the last lap, some
guy was on slick tires,
I was on wets, he was stumbling,
quite a few of them were stumbling.
I was overtaking cars here and there.
I had no idea where I was.
I thought they were back markers.
The guy came across the
line and thought he had,
for a second was world champion,
and then I came across
the line 17 seconds later
and I crossed the line and I thought
I lost the world championship,
so my heart sunk.
I was distraught, and then,
I don't know why they
took so long, but like
12, 13 seconds later they
told me I was world champion.
I mean I didn't know what
the hell was going on.
I think just at the time, after that,
big whirlwind of media,
back at the factory,
there was so much tension.
I guess I was only 23, so
I just didn't feel I was,
don't forget, growing up, instead of
hanging out with friends
on the weekends and
doing normal kid's social
life stuff, I was racing.
I was with adults.
So, I missed that a lot, that
maturity growing up stage.
I don't feel I was mature enough to really
be able to embrace the whole
experience and enjoy it.
So I tell you, it was not a great,
it was, it's amazing that
I won the championship,
but it just wasn't able to enjoy it.
And rolled into the second year,
the year after that for example.
But the last two
championships I've really,
I guess, I'm coming of an age,
been able to really absorb it
and enjoy the moment because
so much work has gone in for my family.
I don't take it for granted,
the opportunity that I have for one.
There are so many people
that would cut their leg off
to be in my seat and do what I do.
So I make sure that I
maximize every time that I get
in the car, I'm representing my family
every time that I get in that car.
And,
so there's nothing,
there's no time for second place.
Of course those experiences,
when you have those lows like
losing the world championship
only make you stronger
when you do, or realize
these heights and lows.
Once you've had the low,
you appreciate the highs even more.
- And so presumably
particularly frustrating
for you this season, I
mean it's early days yet.
- It's a killer season.
It's
terrible. (laughing)
Obviously had a couple of
amazing years, the last two.
I would say this is, luckily through
the experience of the 10
years of racing you kind of,
you have the ups and downs
and I definitely think
these past five races have been
massively testing for myself, my mechanics
for my engineers.
I think each time I see
it as a challenge to rise.
I see it as a challenge to, you know,
I'm going to be facing the media right now
but I feel terrible, I'm
angry that I lost the race
or something like that.
But it's a moment for me to,
kids that are watching, to
me to say the right things.
It's a moment for me to lift my guys up
who are probably feeling
just as much as me.
Or back in the factory who
work non-stop to build my car.
So so much going on, and,
I feel, often when I do it right,
I feel, I come out of it so much stronger.
And so, I do feel this is just
a trials and tribulations.
This is a period of time
of growth for me that,
whilst there's always growth, you know,
I met Nelson Mandela once,
when he was 90, for his 90th
birthday, and he said to me,
that he was still
learning at that time so,
- Wow.
- I have a long way to go.
Hopefully.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed.
I love to know what
was your favorite clip?
What resonated the most with you?
What are you going to take from this video
and immediately apply to your
life or your business somehow?
Please leave it down in the comments,
I'm super curious to find out.
Thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you, I hope you
continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your One Word is, much love.
I'll see you soon.